well president Trump is condemning the
attempted attacks but at a political
rally in Wisconsin last night the
president also blamed his political
opponents and the media for raising
tensions we should Jane covered the
rally as and is with us from Wausau
Wisconsin we do good morning good
morning bianna last night President
Trump called for unity but often at his
rallies he launches some of his harshest
insults at political opponents including
those who were sent the packages and now
some of his own supporters are calling
for both sides to tone down the rhetoric
let's get along great country we're
gonna get along president Trump opened
his campaign rally in central Wisconsin
by condemning violence such conduct must
be fiercely opposed and firmly
prosecuted we want all sides to come
together in peace and harmony he swapped
a fiery stump speech for a softer tone
one even he recognized do you see how
nice some behaving tonight this is like
have you ever seen this we're all
behaving very well and hopefully we can
keep it that way
noticeably missing the president's usual
attacks on political opponents he has
lashed out on all the victims who were
sent suspicious packages Hillary earlier
this month former attorney General Eric
Holder said this about the GOP they go
low we keep triggering this response
from the president you better be careful
what he's wishing for that I can tell
you he's better be careful Hillary
Clinton did not mention mr. Trump by
name when she talked about the threats
in the mail but it is a troubling time
isn't it we have to do everything we can
to bring our country together former CIA
director John Brennan whose security
clearance president Trump revoked in
August was more blunt a lot of this
rhetoric really is counterproductive it
is unamerican
it is what a president should not be
doing some Wisconsin Trump supporters we
met say there's plenty of
blame to go around I think
take a step back
[Music]
certain things are no longer except
last night the president named one of
his main targets as a culprit the media
also has a responsibility to set a civil
tone and to stop the endless hostility
earlier Wednesday CNN worldwide
president Jeff Zucker released a
statement saying there is a total and
complete lack of understanding at the
White House about the seriousness of
their continued attacks on the media he
said the president and especially the
White House press secretary should
understand their words matter
bianna we think you